this is Douglas mature who made this
video while exploring Darwaza in
Turkmenistan oh my god
it's on fire I can feel this is real or
not but I'm a feeling it's fake but then
a part of me still says it's real I'm
not sure well sod will put you out of
your misery it is real but what is it
the nickname for this place is the
doorway to hell
scientifically speaking this is a huge
natural gas reservoir in the 1970s a
team of people went to this site to see
if it was a good place that they could
fill the gas rig what's actually
happened with that when they were
investigating just the amount of natural
gas in this reservoir it collapsed in on
itself started emitting a lot of natural
gas which is colorless odorless
poisonous and highly flammable so they
decided the best way to get rid of this
was to set fire to it and watch the well
burn itself out what they didn't expect
was for it to keep burning and burning
and burning and burning so that now it's
still burning so it's been burning from
more than 40 years but why is there so
much gas natural gas is formed when
organic matter like dead animals and
dead plants gets buried deep below the
earth and subjected to high temperatures
and pressures this breaks down the
carbon-carbon bonds to form a natural
gas and just how long will it burn for
it depends on how much gas is below the
earth as to how long this will burn for
it could burn for an incredibly long
time
you